so i don't want to spend too much time
on macro but uh they say inflation's 8.6
percent now the fed when it was 7 back
in december was still
conducting quantitative easing they
hadn't raised interest rates just what's
your general take in terms of uh maybe
incompetence ignorance how do we get
here and then how much confidence do you
put in their ability to uh navigate a i
think they call it a soft landing now um
euphemistic for a recession like a
moderate recession
moderate unemployment moderate session
um no there's an old paper from milton
freeman in 1972 that you all should read
basically bill freeman argued among many
things but this is probably his number
one nobel prize winning contribution is
that
a federal central decision maker whether
the federal reserve or some other
institution will always get this wrong
they will always
raise rates when they should be lowering
them and lower rates when they should be
raising them basically the lag is too
great so that leads to consistent
oversteering because you're basically
amplifying the problem by the time you
act but then it makes the problem worse
so the best thing to do is to do nothing
in his view and it's a very well argued
paper so this is a classic illustration
of that
but um
right now
i don't know all i can do is go shopping
so this is what i've told several so
people here before just go to the
grocery store and if the price of your
groceries going up every week we have
inflation if they start settling and
being stable then you know we're fine
and then when they start going down
again we'll have deflation which is not
a really good thing but in any event
groceries are still going up as far as i
can tell
the craziest thing to me is uh i don't
know why i did this but one day i went
deep down the rabbit hole of how they
calculated influence oh yeah yeah that's
there's
466 people who are employed by the
bureau of labor statistics and they go
into the grocery store and they're
giving a print out and they make sure
they find the exact campbell soup tomato
with no salt and there's like an 11-page
document to make sure they have the
right one and then they punch it into a
device so yeah so when we were starting
square before we launched we wanted to
build a true inflation tracker so
because we had all these goods and
services obviously you know sales in
real time price adjustments basically in
real time and so when jack started
tweeting about inflation hyperinflation
i was like he's looking at real data
he's not making this stuff up he's not a
macro he's not being a macro thinker
he's actually seeing the data and so it
was so obvious from the square data that
we had real inflation in early 2021 well
it's not just the price and point of
sale stuff there's also uh payroll data
like he kind of has a full 360 view of
the economy to some degree and i think
that it does beg the question so we have
i don't know we can call it like an
analog version of price uh um collection
versus even if you look at apartment.com
or zillow open or like all of these
real-time data points and sometimes 100
million data but they don't use
real-time data so here's the funny guy
there was just a twitter thread about
this this morning so you talk about
leasing
the methodology really matters so if you
say what is the rate of inflation on
rental prices you can calculate it two
different ways and you can you'll
immediately see the difference one is
across all leases in the united states
the other is leases signs in the last
three months guess what one is up like
41 and one is up six percent guess which
one actually tells you where you are
i can only imagine
hey you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time